[Music]
the story of the day generating the most
buzz celebrities rallying around bullied
student Keaton Jones and the story has
taken some wild turns today because
while Keaton's viral video triggered an
outpouring of a list of [ __ ] it also
sparked some unwanted attention for his
family I just want to say you're
inspiring so many people with your
message and your authenticity he's such
a tough cookie and I think that
everybody's rallying around him and love
him JLo Jimmy Lovato Katy Perry just a
few of the star standing with Keaton
pitch perfect threes Hailee Steinfeld
even invited him to tomorrow's Hollywood
premiere now I would love for you
Keaton Jones to be my date and Captain
America himself Chris happens extended a
similar invite to next year's premiere
of Avengers infinity war that's the
Spanish shoot the video has been viewed
more than 20 million times since the
middle schoolers mom posted it last
Friday the four that are different don't
need to be criticized Beth but now a
photo believed to be Keaton's mom posing
with a confederate flag has surfaced on
social media
Ichi hasn't verified the photo but it's
already triggering some backlash
Patricia Arquette tweeted quote his mom
needs to see her views are the same as
those causing many of those kids to be
bullied Keaton's sister today responded
that her mother who has made her
Facebook page private is not racist but
a little boy who didn't deserve to be
bullied may now find things won't get
better
just yet Keating I just want to say you
are a legend your beast your boss you're
an icon listen at the end of the day all
that matters are the babies those little
kids
[Music]